let's stay with presidential Politics
the 2024 race Donald Trump has been
receiving a little bit of criticism from
different circles about the fact that he
doesn't really have any policy
prescriptions for 2024. he rolled onto
the scene in 2015 rolled down his
escalator and came out and called
Mexicans rapists they're not sending
their best
they're sending their worst the rapists
and the drugs and the and I assume some
of them are good people you'll remember
and then it was Muslim bans and and all
of the rest
and now where do you go from there
it seems because Ron DeSantis again it
seems to be the chief opponent that we
will see
it seems that Donald Trump is going to
try to out DeSantis Ron DeSantis out
bigot Ron DeSantis out homophobe Ron
DeSantis he is going to try to
anti-trans bigot
off the charts and this is one of the
first policy prescriptions that Donald
Trump Allah his wall except now he wants
to oppress a marginalized population in
the United States here's Donald Trump
talking about what he wants to do with
education and trans rights
as part of our new credentialing body
for teachers we will promote positive
education about the nuclear family the
roles of mothers and fathers and
celebrating rather than erasing the
things that make men and women different
and unique I will ask Congress to pass a
bill establishing that the only genders
recognized by the United States
government are male and female and they
are assigned at Birth this is damaging
rhetoric it's obviously goofy coming out
of the mouth of this pumpkin head but
this is dangerous the the trans
population in the United States and
likely the world uh possesses some of
the highest suicide rates
among any group
this is hateful this is damaging this is
harmful and for Donald Trump to tout
education about the nuclear family
what's next for Donald Trump well we're
gonna my new policy prescription is to
teach people to have sex with porn stars
and then pay them off with a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars cheat on all my
wives this is what you have to do to be
a good Christian man in America and
we're going to sign a bill to make it so
this is hypocrisy this is hate this is
xenophobia and really it boils down to
where does Donald Trump go from here
he's already he's played the greatest
hits we've seen the greatest hits in
2016. he tried to replace some of that
in 2020 he created new things to whine
and complain about and fear Monger about
in 2020. so where does he go from here
he's gonna have to level up he's going
to have to ramp up the hatred and the
bigotry and the xenophobia
and the racism he's going to have to do
that to to reconnect to the base to
inflame their passions this is what he's
going to have to do and listen I don't
know
I fear for the country I fear for
marginalized groups look I'm gonna be
okay
I'm a white guy in America
I could I could fail up and down the
street and still do okay
but it's it's marginalized groups it's
those desperate people coming from other
countries trying to make a better life
for themselves and Escape
brutality in their home countries that
are going to suffer it's the lgbtq
community in this country that will
suffer it is a rogue Maga Supreme Court
that has been appointed by Donald Trump
that's going to enact bring to fruition
this type of Oppression
we need to to brace ourselves for the
fight ahead we need to enlist those
around us who have compassion and
empathy for humankind to get to the
polls
your family your neighbors your friends
your co-workers your acquaintances these
conversations while uncomfortable need
to be talked about because you may know
a republican you may think to yourself
ah that prayer he's a decent person
yeah he votes Republican but he doesn't
he doesn't care if if gay people get
married
but if that person this good and decent
person votes for someone who then
oppresses with their legislation who
then votes and enacts policy that does
oppress people
how is that good and decent person any
better than what they enacted through
their votes
and I think this is the way we need to
talk about this going forward into 2024
because we've witnessed
from a distance fortunately for me but
some not from a distance millions of
people live in Florida they've witnessed
Ron DeSantis and the things he's been
able to accomplish with his Republican
majority
they're trying to turn America in to
Florida and that is a terrifying
proposition
so I hope that you become as passionate
as I feel about this and move into 2024
to combat this nonsense because as scary
as it was in 2016 and as scary as it
could have been
after the 2020 election it's gonna get
worse
I hope you're in for it
as many people know I'm a white ale type
of guy when it comes to beer and even
for those of us who drink responsibly
like me
sometimes you still feel it the next day
and it can slow you down especially when
you start to get up there in the years
like me check out our sponsor zebiotics
which is a probiotic drink that breaks
down the byproduct of alcohol
responsible for those rough mornings
after drinking all you do is drink a
tiny bottle of zebiotics before you have
alcohol next day you'll feel refreshed
and ready to go the way it works is when
you drink a toxic byproduct builds up in
your gut and that's what causes you to
feel bad the next day zibiotics produces
an enzyme to break down that byproduct
and zibiotic stands by their product 100
if it doesn't work for you you get all
your money back no questions asked
remember we're talking about drinking
responsibly here I can't more highly
prioritize getting a good night's sleep
zibiotics is for responsible drinkers
who just want to get the most out of the
next day go to zebiotics.com Pacman get
at 15 off your first order with the code
Pacman the link is down below